all right let's start in a way we
haven't started for a while which is by
talking about the coronavirus pandemic
you know i got a few emails from people
saying david
if you want to be fair you've got to
call out joe biden for something that he
recently said
joe biden recently said the pandemic is
over that's not true and if you're going
to be fair you can't let that slide well
i call out anybody who says things that
aren't true and joe biden did on 60
minutes say the pandemic is over and the
pandemic is not over and i will make
that case in a moment but maybe maybe
not in the way you would assume i would
make it so let's first listen to what
joe biden said
mr president first detroit auto show in
three years yeah
is the pandemic over
the pandemic
is over we still have a problem with
covet we're still doing a lot of work on
it
uh it's but the pandemic is over if you
notice no one's wearing masks everybody
seems to be in pretty good shape
and so i think it's changing and i think
this is a perfect example of it this is
pretty silly it really is now there's
two interpretations here when joe biden
says listen the pandemic is over as
evidenced by
the auto show is back there's no masks
and everyone here seems to be doing okay
you know forget about the millions that
have died for a second
but this really isn't true now this
isn't about me i am not saying i need to
hold on to every guideline we ever had
no i mean i'm not wearing masks i'm out
in the world i'm doing things this is
not a question of of me
my behavior is basically back to normal
but it's not true that the pandemic is
over when you look at the sort of
numbers that we have right now in the
united states you know an average of
somewhere between 60 and 90 000 new
cases a day would we had a hundred cases
a day at the start of the pandemic it
was a disaster we now have 60 to 90 000
that we know of and probably two or
three times more from people doing home
tests are not getting tested at all when
you look at the death numbers
we still have somewhere between
you know three and five hundred people
dying every single day from covid so
here are the things joe biden could have
said that would have been true
we've gotten accustomed to the current
level of death from covid
and we consider it normal and acceptable
and a fair exchange to going back to our
normal lives generally speaking that
would have been an accurate statement
from joe biden or
we don't think we really can reduce the
number of deaths from where they are
right now
so we're not even really going to try
okay i mean that that would have been an
accurate statement
um i think it is true to say that
politically the pandemic rhetoric has
ended
um but there's no real way
mathematically to make the case that the
pandemic is over and
to be clear
i am not coming at this from i'm trying
to get everybody back in their homes and
wearing masks and no large gatherings or
anything i'm not advocating for any of
that i'm part of
the group that has said you know it
seems like it's going to be like this at
least for a few more years
and at a certain point it's
understandable that for the most part
most people have gone completely back to
normal am i going to large sporting
events right now no i'm not but i was
already kind of starting not to before
the pandemic just because the crowds are
annoying and i hate sitting in traffic
and all of that stuff but um to say the
pandemic is over you can't really back
it up with any statistical data and so
what we have done and it's okay to
accept this it is i mean a similar thing
happened after the flu pandemic of 1918.
the pandemic ends
culturally and socially in a way
before there is any medical end to the
pandemic and because covet is a little
different and we see
without getting now into the medical
part of it between variants and all
these other things
it's likely going to be around for a
while if not longer than a while the
medical end may not come for a period of
time it may not ever come in a sense but
the political end the social end the
cultural end we expected would happen
sooner now what will things look like in
january who knows but that would be a
more fair assessment as of right now so
joe biden is just wrong
i still agree with student loan debt
forgiveness
i still think the inflation reduction
act is good
i still think joe biden has done a lot
more good things than many recent
presidents but on this particular thing
he simply isn't correct
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one american uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
soft toilet paper real paper loves the
david pakman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to real paper
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman at checkout the link is down
below